speculos 2C does look promising though
it's about 40 percent larger than Earth
there's also the potential for it being
a rocky planet just like ours
now despite the fact that it also exists
in a habitable zone it's red dwarf star
is still very small it's only about 15
percent the size of our sun
so this planet orbits around its star at
a very close distance
and this close distance could mean that
speculos 2C is tidally locked to its
star
this super Earth takes eight and a half
days to make one full rotation on its
axis as well as one orbit around its
star
that would leave one side of the planet
in constant daylight and the other in
Endless Night
this means that life could be possible
in The Terminator Zone